[Musique]
nous sommes vraiment un couple pas comme
les autres
nous n'avons pas de chansons même pas
d'alliance on peut remédier à ça je le
veux et toi
je n'ai pas fait sans mal
[Applaudissements]
cet endroit
je ne comprends pas ce qui se passe
mais c'est la grande vedette dix
spectacles
veux tu dire
à
et ils vécurent heureux et eurent
beaucoup d'enfants
oui
vraiment
[Musique]
mais qu'est-ce que célibataire comme
vous peut bien faire dans une maison est
si gigantesque mais je vous assure que
je suis mariée un humain un homme
parfait et grands on t'as beau chace
break
cela
le couple pas comme les autres
oh nous n'en avons jamais douté une
seconde
nous ne savons pas ce qui va nous
arriver
salut les voisins saluent bien
en dames et qu'est-ce qu'il prend qui es
tu je suis sur la suisse
y'a un truc qui cloche ici
re soleil qui est ce qui vous fait ça
nous sommes si non alors il faut qu'on
se batte
[Musique]
je crois comme un régler l affaire